is life worth living without
thanksgiving
in oregon violators of rules against
large gatherings could face jail time
where they will be gathered in large
groups in jails with other violators
for the last eight months i have been
asking oregonians to follow
the letter and the spirit of the law and
we have not chosen to engage law
enforcement
at this point in time unfortunately we
have
no other option no other options in
other states leaders
vow fines and also jail time while some
just freak out
first of all let's try not to be
obnoxious
and offensive in your tone
if by the state's numbers you hit
three percent the schools close
how what are you talking about you're
now going to override
we did it already that's the law an
orange zone in a red zone
follow the facts still confused well
then you're confused
i'm confused parents
he needs that large q-tip to clear out
his ears i wonder if his brother still
has it
meanwhile photos emerged of gavin newsom
partying up as he lectures you
on shutting down this as the pa governor
orders you to wear a mask at home
which is fine with me i've been doing
that for years but this is getting gross
seriously we're adults who already work
together to save the most vulnerable
lives
i mean you flattened the curve not the
politicians you saved the lives not the
media
you pulled it off not them so it's hard
to be lectured by bozos who did nothing
and it's hard to sit by while rules are
enforced differently for other people
it's always the righteous who break
their own laws flying off to maui or
faking quarantine and then they wag
their fingers at you who are the heroes
then they excuse the mob who don't just
violate social distancing
but also your personal space your event
is a super spreader
theirs of course is heroism so it's jail
time if you visit granny
but a woman who spits in a cop's face
she's out in a few hours
in a pandemic how's that not assault
with a deadly weapon
well when the media shapes the story
cops are evil so spit away
so the public should be pissed off we
know it's fun being a tyrant
but we know what to do we don't want our
relatives to die so don't insult
us by saying we don't care your threats
make us seethe
so my advice for thanksgiving for all of
you is why not make some signs
and call it a protest tell everyone
you're speaking truth to turkey
just wear a mask and keep your distance
and do it for granny
and not for the governors all right
kennedy you are the libertarian
in this company um this is this
is an interesting challenge because this
is really about
what america is it's about freedom and
risk
give me liberty or give me death we can
have both
yes and and the idea that you have to
sacrifice
uh freedom for security that has been
shown to be a false paradigm
but you know you said just make some
signs and call it a protest
all you have to do for the busy bodies
outside
your kitchen with binoculars is uh just
hold up some
biden harris paraphernalia and say no no
we're celebrating yes we're celebrating
the victory
and they'll be like okay no that's fine
the virus knows the virus is political
it knows not to attack people
who are standing shoulder to shoulder
celebrating rather this great victory
but we do have to be very mindful of our
own actions that doesn't mean
and i sincerely thought that once
election day came and went
that that would be the end of the virus
fuss
budgetary but it has only begun and
that's because people who are in power
who have a dim view of other human
beings now want to control them more
than ever
especially with the vaccine on the
horizon because they know with the
vaccine there is hope
and that means that the doors will once
be open for businesses churches and
schools
so they have to do whatever they can to
concentrate power
and those could have long-term bad
effects what if anybody will look at a
surge in cases
two weeks after the biden celebrations i
doubt anybody's gonna do that
so dana they also said uh experts are
saying no
singing no loud music and no alcohol
what's left for you
oh well i can't sing at all
um the alcohol thing yeah we're gonna
have a fight um
about that i do but i was thinking it's
not like for me
if the issue is you know speaking loudly
or singing like i laugh
loud like and i enjoy a good laugh
that's one of the great things about
thanksgiving so
i i do think that for some of these
people who are in
government or in public they're that are
in person
people who are in power okay so let's
take governor cuomo or somebody like
kate brown out out in oregon
like i i don't have her responsibility
like i could only take care of myself
and my family and do the right thing for
me and and
that's it you know we have a public
health department for a reason like
they go around and they give the
restaurants a grade
and we need that yeah right and i also
do have
some empathy for these uh doctors and
nurses who
you see them on the news they're
exhausted they're tired and some of
these
hospitals can't handle the load so i
understand what they're trying to do but
when it comes to somebody like mayor de
blasio and the schools
he had this arbitrary number three
percent positive cases means we shut
down the schools again but it doesn't
take into account any other things that
we've learned
there's not been these big spreads from
schools to teachers teachers to students
or um so what he's done is he's
failing the students because he can't
come to an agreement with the adults
and i think that we will pay a big price
but we want like the
the children who are missing out on a
year of school or more
they're going to take pay a big price i
just want to mention one other thing
about that
friend of mine has a colleague she and
her husband both work
um they have a seven-year-old son who is
adhd he has not been able to go to the
in-person school
he cannot learn on line he's basically
missed an entire year of school he has
forgotten how to read
that should be unacceptable to all of us
yeah that's another casualty uh jesse we
we hear about drug overdoses suicides
depression
uh this this delayed education is going
to hurt people in lower
income and other brackets the wealthy
are going to be able to get through this
just hire a private tutor
i'm going to have to bribe my children
into college somehow
some way hopefully i can afford it under
the biden economy
i mean there's nothing in the
constitution that says i can't
invite uncle jimmy over for dessert yeah
if aunt sue wants to break out into song
i'm supposed to tell her that's against
the law or i can't scream when the lions
don't cover on thanksgiving
i can't have a drink that's crazy but i
want to talk about this
mask worshipping i wear a mask in
manhattan
but if i don't wash my hands or social
distance and the mask
is useless where all these little hot
spots are popping up whether it's
california
wisconsin minnesota illinois
all of those states have had mask
mandates for months they're run by
democrats
it's not the silver bullet they just had
an outbreak at the mayo clinic
yep an outbreak at the world health
organization these aren't
trump-friendly territories the royal
family's getting sick
professional athletes have caught kova
democrat politicians have caught it
there's only so much you can do against
the virus the virus will always win
so anytime someone catches covet in this
country it's not one politician's fault
it's not donald trump's fault you have
to lower the mortality as best you can
and you have to wait for a vaccine at
the same time you have to stay clean
but to have these ridiculous regulations
around thanksgiving
when the politicians enacting them
aren't following them themselves
it's kind of like having a fat trainer
why am i
taking your advice if you're not taking
your own advice
he might be big boned big bone he's a
hefty trainer that's
true don't fat shame the trainers sorry
greg i apologize
last word to you well i understand that
people don't like to have the government
telling them what to do here
right no one likes that right
libertarian over here
uh but on the other hand i think that
there comes a point where individual
actions
impact the safety of us all and you know
the easiest example would be speeding
obviously you can't drive your car as
fast as you might want to because that
impacts other people you could crash
into other people hurt yourself
kill people and the like these days
you're not allowed to smoke indoors
uh you know certainly can't smoke on an
airplane that's again
because of us americans as
a family looking out for each other and
i think in this way we have to start to
think
more openly about why these regulations
are in place it's not about
democrats today we had i think it's
three or four
maybe more republican governors say i'm
now going to impose some
limits whether it's mass or other limits
in terms of gatherings
so you're seeing now i think a little
bit moving away from the trump
steel handle oh no we're not having a
lockdown now i think you see
republican governor saying listen the
reason we're doing this
is not just by fiat but because we have
such a tremendous
increase in the rate of infection we
have such a high level of people
hospitalized and our hospitals are
reaching capacity in terms of dealing
with this
and it's a lagging indicator but we see
an increase in deaths
that's a public health crisis for
america not republican not
democrat but for us all right now i
think
hospital capacity is nowhere near that i
think that
the last numbers i checked with
wisconsin was the worst had 10 percent
with
co patients which is still bad